[Musique]
découvrir les versants de la rivière des
remparts et admirer ses paysages des
eaux du volcan pour ces personnes
porteuses de handicap c'est une première
grâce à ces aménagements l'air d'accueil
du piton nez de boeuf est maintenant
accessible à tous on va pouvoir faire
une sortie il ya même un terrain de
boules on pourra faire de la pétanque
effet à faire cuire à manger les chios
soit ménages et donc bien très bientôt
va venir passer une journée j avec 800
mètres linéaires de béton fibré ce site
est désormais l'un des plus grands
chemins aménagés pour personnes à
mobilité réduite en milieu naturel
c'est un des chantiers importants
puisque c'est un financement de plus de
400000 euros financé à 75% par l'union
européenne et à 25% par l'appartement
aujourd'hui nous avons 17 sites qui sont
accessibles et c'est vrai l'objectif
c'est de pouvoir ouvrir encore plus nous
avons eu tellement magnifique donc il
est normal que même les personnes à
mobilité réduite les personnes âgées les
familles les enfants puissent en
profiter un maximum
développer les hauts de l'île et
permettre l'accessibilité pour tous des
plus beaux sites de la réunion
c'est l'engagement pris par la nfl le
département en diversifiant les aires
d'accueil du piton nez de boeuf avec de
nouvelles structures la collectivité
continue sa stratégie de développement
économique touristique et écologique du
massif forestier du volcan sommes sur un
site exceptionnel où nous avons en face
de nous les les neiges à moins de
pied l'appel des caves un espace
exceptionnel qui
fait partie du patrimoine de galles
[Musique]